what kind of music gets you pumped up
like what would our tag team go into
what music oh anything hardcore hardcore
rap hip-hop rap yeah i love that you
mentioned hip-hop because we're going to
keep it right there because only 18's
cassie delauro was backstage at the bet
hip-hop awards in atlanta for nelly's
big night
it's a big night for you
it's incredible you know what i'm saying
you're very very grateful
i heard there might be some clothes
coming off because it's going to get hot
no i don't know about all that
it was definitely nelly's night as he
closed the bet hip-hop awards with an
epic medley
[Applause]
the performance came just after taking
home the im hip hop award which included
some surprise shout outs the
conversations of band-aids bigger
jerseys baggy jeans he created one of
the greatest love songs of history and
i'm always grateful to him for that
[Music]
we're talking 23 years later and it's
kind of a full circle moment so i'm just
i'm just honored you know i feel a
little old but it's okay
l.l you having fun tonight i'm having a
great time ll cool j hit the stage to
present the first ever rock the bells
cultural influence award to tyler the
creator i said okay okay how do you
think you will celebrate after this
award getting right back on the plane i
got things to do tomorrow and tyler had
the luggage to prove it you always bring
an extra t-shirt and stuff we're
literally jetting right out of here and
you have your luggage with you yeah i
have everything with me cardi b and
meghan the stallion ruled the night with
three wins they did not attend but
mccannon's alter ego murder count harlem
sure did are the crocs comfortable on
the red carpet socks and my crocs
who are you excited to see tonight me
[Music]
you